I'm Max and I'm the luckiest dog in New
York because of her by Jesus salon now
see you later
stop guys today I got big plans I'm
gonna sit here and I'm gonna wait for
Katie to come back oh I miss her so much
I have some big news
this is Dooku you're going to be your
brother Chloe Chloe I got a bad
situation Katie brought home a
psychopath from the pound I don't even
have a bed now I'm sleeping on the floor
like a dog Lucas is ruining our lives
you know cutie pie your own business oh
my gosh what happened to you Katie's
gonna be worried sick we had a great
thing going I blame myself yeah me too
I blame you a lot
what Buster both you out of here but
from that one you work for me
advantage me oh just ignore what just
happened okay
this is my city
I'm fine your friend we gotta take this
secret rep okay the secret route was dad
we can find our way home we are
descended from the mighty wolf
we have raw primal instincts hi how are
you there are moments away from leading
us home isn't home that way
seriously the secret life of this
be a good boy Leonard
heckler first unmanned